one way of visualizing an economy is as
a big system connected by wiring and
circuitry the supply chains that feed us
stock up our businesses and provide us
energy but what happens when that
circuitry fails us it's a question we're
now beginning to answer as Supply chains
falter and prices start to rise putting
companies under pressure we are seeing
increases across all raw materials and
it's understanding how we can mitigate
those costs with those suppliers
unfortunately you know some some of
those supplies are increasing their
costs not once but twice and even three
times that then becomes you know
difficult conversations with our
customers
an energy crisis is an everything crisis
hence why you hear similar complaints
from every sector from manufacturing to
agriculture to Services groups like this
restaurant
energy is a big one
um because it hits you in terms of your
your bills the bills you pay to uh to
operate the places but of course it hits
all our suppliers so you know some of
our suppliers have asked for a surcharge
to deal with the current cost of fuel
this is a big big Challenge and um you
know you you can see a lot of businesses
running into trouble in the coming
months
with speculation growing we're now
heading for a recession and with fresh
figures showing gross domestic products
GDP falling 0.3 in April it's tempting
to believe we're already in a slump but
don't be so sure look a little closer
here's a question up until recently what
is it you saw in pretty much every High
Street in the country that's right covid
vaccination centers testing centers
there's one over there one further down
the High Street as well and it's the
absence of that activity that's pushing
down on GDP in fact if it wasn't for
that you would have seen gross in April
but while we may not be in a slump yet
that doesn't mean we won't face one soon
the fear is that with prices now so high
people simply stop spending talk to
motorists and it seems we may be nearing
that point I'm a small business owner
been about 10 years now and it's
crippling at the moment running two or
three vans is just terrible
where we spend about 80 pounds a week
it's 150 per vehicle now everything has
had an impact we've sold our house
that's on the outskirts of a town and
we're moving into the city center so
that we can be closer to our jobs and
we're not going to have a long commute
anymore as well
this is a squeeze the likes of which we
haven't seen for more than a generation
last time we had anything like this it
ushered in years of stagnation and
suffering the hope is history doesn't
repeat itself but history has a habit of
doing just that
Conway Sky News